[Music]
welcome to the undiscovered corners of
hotel transylvania from its all-star
voice cast headlined by selena gomez
adam sandler and andy samberg as well as
the lovable monsters and the unique
world they live in the hotel
transylvania films have given us plenty
of spooky silly fun a lot went into
creating this franchise that has won
over the hearts of fans of all ages and
some of it was never even able to reach
the big screen
welcome to hotel transylvania
the opening of hotel transylvania almost
began a couple years earlier an
alternate opening nicknamed love at
first bite featured dracula meeting his
beloved martha and the story of how they
fell in love leading up to the birth of
their daughter mavis while the opening
doesn't go full up and reveal martha's
passing the alternate opening certainly
tugs on the viewer's heartstrings
that being said it's easy to see why
this scene was left on the cutting room
floor as it would have taken away from
the emotional impact of the reveal of
martha's fate later in the film and it
was no mystery who killed her
in a montage that would have played
towards the beginning of the first film
we see several of the monstrous guests
pack up their suitcases and leave their
homes for a relaxing trip to drax hotel
among the travelers are frankenstein and
his wife eunice traveling inside heavy
suitcases from their decaying windmill
home murray sneaking out of his pyramid
a bug-like monster creeping out from the
english sewers and mr foote trying to
blend in with his surroundings during
his travels this scene may be creative
but it simply does not add anything to
the film's plot and was likely cut out
to help make the film's pacing tighter
though this scene did end up making the
teaser trailer
tired of the same old vacation spots
this deleted scene from hotel
transylvania 2 features a commercial for
humans promoting their titular hotel
taking pride in the truce between
monsters and humans the commercial is
hosted by a fly monster who expresses to
a confused human family about how all
the hotel's amenities as well as talking
about how monsters have been integrated
into the human world including griffin
the invisible man hosting a workout
video and mr foote being a star in the
german soccer league while this scene
does serve as some effective exposition
the sequel eventually figures out a more
effective way at letting the audience
know about what has changed since we
last saw the drak pack
this deleted scene from the first hotel
transylvania may have had andy samberg
burst into a rap using his lonely island
cords the scene would have had johnny
offering his take on more modern and hip
music for mavis's 118th birthday with a
wrap that gives a hip-hop spin to the
spooky inhabitants of the titular hotel
as fun as it may have been to see
sandberg bring some of his lonely island
flavor for a scene in the film it's not
hard to see why this did not make the
final product as it doesn't complement
the genuine and sweet nature of the film
as a whole
since murray's voice actor in the first
film was celo green the team behind the
film wanted to put the singer's vocal
chords to good use originally murray was
supposed to have a song and dance number
along with his backup singers known as
the mummettes the actual song that
murray and his bandaged rapt
accompanists would have sung has not
been revealed but it surely had to have
been something spooky
selena gomez has been an active part of
the franchise since the first film in
2012 but before she was cast in the role
another disney channel icon turned
global superstar almost took on the role
of drak's daughter mavis miley cyrus
what cyrus was originally announced to
be voicing the character of mavis but
was eventually fired from the project
after photos surfaced of her doing some
activities that were not particularly
family friendly the studio and cyrus
eventually announced that she would no
longer be voicing mavis and that
replacing her would be gomez looking
back at the movies now gomez definitely
seemed like the perfect fit for the role
they even look alike oh my gosh this is
gonna be so much fun
it's become commonplace for actors to
come and go from the franchise while
singer celo greene initially provides
his voice for the role of marie the
mummy in the first film for the second
third and fourth films he was replaced
by keegan michael key even two of the
biggest marquee names of the hotel
transylvania franchise didn't return for
the fourth film transfermania adam
sandler and kevin james voice actors
brian hull and brad abreal eventually
were cast to replace sandler and james
in the roles of dracula and frankenstein
thankfully hull and abrell are also
impressionists and were able to give
voices that sound almost exactly like
the voices of sandler and james one
wouldn't typically expect family films
populated by kooky and silly monsters to
attempt to strive for accuracy but you
would be surprised the town that the
hotel is located in was directly
influenced by volakia bulgaria the
birthplace of the inspiration behind
dracula vlad the impaler while obviously
there's no real hotel for monsters in
the historical village the film's
architecture is heavily lifted from the
town
mavis and jonathan's precious son dennis
is notable for his poofy red hair but it
was almost even more wild in the
original designs the animation team then
realized the circumference of the
original design for the hair was too big
to even be functional and would have
meant that his parents arms would need
to be double the length in order to even
pick him up this led the animation team
to eventually trim dennis's hair to a
more sustainable look
i got a candy though dennis walking
around with an abnormally large red set
of hair would have been quite amusing to
watch
one of the biggest challenges the hotel
transylvania crew faced while making the
film was animating the kraken at the end
of the third film summer vacation the
team had to build three different
krakens the first being the standard
model the second being one that was
required for when the sea monster
performs the macarena and the third
being what was dubbed a stunticle that
had texture and look dev that would hold
up during close-up shots
much of the zany cast of characters in
the hotel transylvania are directly
inspired by the actors who voice them
the looks of dracula mavis jonathan
frankenstein wayne van helsing and
eunice are directly taken from the
actors who voice them adam sandler
selena gomez andy samberg kevin james
steve buscemi jim gaffigan and fran
drescher no wonder they look so familiar
meanwhile for the other characters such
as murray the mummy and griffin the
invisible man the character design team
had to get a bit more creative
quite a bit went into creating the
character of vlad voiced by the iconic
mel brooks vlad's head shape was
designed to look like a coffin a
callback to the tradition that vampires
sleep in coffins for the aging vampire's
home initially the team debated about
having the character live in a dark and
foreboding castle like something out of
the classic vampire movies ultimately
the team went with a cave to show just
how secluded vlad had become from
civilization you know classic vampire
things
if the legacy cruise ship in the third
film summer vacation looks familiar to
you that's because the ship's design is
directly influenced by the infamous rms
titanic from the ship's black white and
red color scheme to the funnels on the
top the ship clearly resembles the
well-known dreaded ocean liner more so
than the modern ones that the audience
is typically used to
adam sandler is known for including his
real-life family and plenty of his
comedies and that's no different with
hotel transylvania sandler's wife jackie
sandler lended her voice to drock's late
wife martha while his daughters sadie
and sunny sandler have voiced both mavis
as a child as well as wayne and wanda's
werewolf pups the sandlers have to stick
together
since gendi tartovsky has had much
experience with 2d animation he used the
hotel transylvania films to pay tribute
to the tech's avery cartoons that he
grew up with the biggest challenge with
this method was how to take the
organicness of 2d that has no rules
attached and meld it with computer
animation which has more restrictions
the hotel transylvania films have
provided audiences of all ages with
plenty of fun and the franchise has
certainly come a long way since the
first film premiered back in september
of 2012. which hotel transylvania movie
is your favorite